[Captions by Y Translator]
Hey guys. Today,
we are back with Joseph,
who you may recognize from when
he taught us how to do some
basic beginning
blacksmithing techniques.
Today, you're going to be
showing us some techniques
for increasing our strength
and our coordination,
and just how well we control the Hammers.
[Music]
We're gonna play a game of horse,
except it's going to be a game of Smith,
because we're going to spell S-M-I-T-H.
The idea for this comes
from some advice I got from
a blacksmith whose name was Panslayer.
He said that one time,
he was putting a nail up
for his wife in his house,
and he was hitting with a hammer,
and it just so happens that he hit
with the wrong end of the hammer,
and didn't realize it until after
he put the nail in perfectly.
That's the kind of hammer control
that you really need to aspire to
if you're going to get
into blacksmithing.
So that you can put the hammer
exactly where you want it,
exactly how hard you want it,
at exactly the angle you want it.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got some hammers,
we've got some nails,
and we've got an anvil,
and we're going to play some games that
teach us the basics of metal manipulation.
So here's what we're going to play,
and we're going to sink in an nail.
You have to call how many hits
you're going to get it in,
what part of the hammer
you're going to get it in with,
any other weird stuff,
and you have to do it whilst
and at the same time holding the nail only
with a pair of tongs.
And that's because almost everything
when you're blacksmithing,
you won't just hold it with your hand.
Yes.
You're holding it with tongs.
So if you've ever wanted
to watch me lose at a game,
now is a good time.
I've never played this
before, we'll find out.
I'm just going to start out
as basic as humanly possible,
and I'm just going to go
for straight with a regular grip,
and can I predict that it's going to go
in a little bit before bending
in a weird angle...
Yes!
And then having to
flatten it down oddly?
Okay, let's do that.
That's
I mean, that's
my realistic prediction.
Oh, see, one shot.
I'm already at an angle,
and there's a slight curve
in the nail.
So this is going real good.
Like nine shots,
and it's at an angle,
but it did go into the wood.
Oh, and in fact,
it went out the bottom.
We might need a little
bit more wood here.
We're going to end up
filling our table with...
Workbench, we ask for forgiveness.
--Of holes.
I humbly suggest
that we upgrade.
Oh, smaller nails.
Yes, let's do that.
Okay, so you went straight
in normal grip.
I'm gonna try that
with my tutor nail.
Your turn.
So I'm going to try
and drive a finishing nail,
which has like no head to it,
using the back of my hammer.
The part that's not supposed
to be used for nails.
This is going to go great.
Nope.
Yes.
I'm really good at this guys.
Ow?
All right, we're keeping count.
I think that was
about 30 strikes.
I wanna see if I can do that.
You look at this wood here.
Look at that.
Just mark after mark after mark,
where the back of this just completely
missed the nail,
smashed the wood.
That's lovely.
Let's just say after you attempt mine,
you then get to go first,
and I have to try
and replicate yours.
Yes, let's do that.
So it's just better
than, not pass fail.
Okay.
I like this.
We can work on a spectrum.
I don't think I've done better
than you're, you're
at about 45 strikes now.
Who's counting?
Me, so I can win.
Okay, fair enough.
First letter, I get an S.
So I'm going to try it
with this one.
>> See if the ball peen [audible]
>> Ball peen hammer.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, beat that one.
That was like 27 strikes.
[Music]
27, and bent at the same angle.
I think you made the shot.
I think we'll just
call that one a tie.
Okay, so no letters
aside for a tie.
You get to choose
the next shot.
All right, I'm going to go
for the regular head of the hammer.
But I'm going to do it
at an angle.
I kind of want to try it at an angle.
So let's go in for about
a 45 degree angle here.
[Music]
I don't know about 45,
it kinda...
At an angle?
[Music]
See, good practice should be harder
than the real thing,
and I think it might achieve that goal.
[Music]
I think you take that one.
That is--
I think that's more
of the angle we were going for.
So the letter goes to me.
Okay, letter goes to you.
So S and S.
One thing that I find
I frequently have to do
is I will get my thing out of the forge,
bring it to the anvil,
and it will be at an
awkward angle with my tongs.
So this time the thing that you
need to do is go pick up your nail
with one grip of the tongs,
and then reposition your tongs
opposite the way it was.
So I was like this,
you're going to switch like this,
and then just sink it straight down.
[Music]
Better than that.
All right.
So we're starting
with standard grip.
I need to reverse grip.
Uh huh.
And then you were pounding
it reverse grip.
Yeah.
I think?
Or did I get it backwards?
I think I might have done it backwards.
[Music]
>> Awesome.
>> That's kind of in there.
Okay, M for me.
Here's what I'm going
to try this time.
Sure.
I'm going to see if without the nail
touching the board or falling,
I can actually rotate it 360 using
just the hammer and the pliers.
This is actually
really good practice.
That's a really good idea.
Saved it.
[Music]
Yes, okay, 360.
We'll just let you pull it off.
Pretty sick though.
[Music]
I think you did that.
I think you probably
even beat me on speed too.
That looked--
To me, that looked like you
were a little bit faster.
So I think I take
the letter on that.
Okay, we both have S and M.
This is a pretty
even game so far.
So you're going to stand
to the end of the anvil,
like this, this is your anvil,
and we're going to pretend you're
like upsetting a bar just
where you're trying to make it fatter
instead of thinner by shoving some
more material into it.
So this you can kind of
sort of get the shot in real life.
Okay.
[Music]
Yeah, that's
about where it went.
Okay.
I've got 12.
[Music]
That's my 12.
So I'm an SMI.
Next challenge is going
to be straightening a nail,
and for this one, I'll show you
a little bit about how to do that.
Nailed it.
Whenever you bend a nail,
it's always going to be
kind of U shape.
You can think of it as being shaped
either like a U or like an N.
Whenever you hit it,
you want it to be shaped like an N.
I'm going to put it like this,
because if I hit it like this,
and I'm trying to straighten it,
I'm going to get this seesaw motion going,
were it just wants to move my tongs.
[Music]
Okay, that's
relatively straight.
Yeah straighter than that.
Here's my similarly bent nail.
[Music]
It's kinda straight.
It looks pretty good.
Let's compare
to the other ones.
That's kind of straight.
I would say neither
of them is perfectly straight.
But both of them are
somewhat straight.
I think yours is straighter,
it kind of rolls.
Whereas mine like turns over,
and then just like nah, I don't...
That's a good test.
That's smart.
[Music]
This went well.
All right, more time
straightening the nail needed.
A little more hammer
control needed.
You know, a good form
of practice is the one
that's going to challenge you.
I feel challenged.
I do too.
[Music]
Oh boy.
I, I got a letter on that one.
It's so hard.
Yeah!
So I just want to
point something out.
If you look at the video
of me trying to drive this nail in,
I'm pretty sure I started
with my hand back here.
I was like no, no,
I want more power on this one.
That was a mistake.
If you look at his,
he started with his hand
like up here, and the nail
went like pretty straight down
with a not perfectly straight nail.
So like he said before,
you want to hold the Hammer
as far back as you can, as long
as you still have perfect control.
I had not perfect control.
I'm going to do wide nail.
This thing has a bigger head.
[Music]
Yes.
So that was, that
was about 60 strikes.
It was.
But I think, more importantly
for me it will just be
if I can pull it off at all.
I don't have super
high hopes on that front.
[Music]
It's not going well.
Oh, no.
I did make it.
Yeah, kind of.
But I think that still
does definitely goes to you.
Okay.
I took more strikes.
I definitely had it bend back
and forth more times,
and it is at more of an angle now.
I'm impressed that you saved it,
but I'll take the point.
So alright,
So I'm... I'm SMIT.
SMIT.
Okay, last point.
Okay.
So the shot is going
to be three nails,
not just one this time.
We're going to go one,
place it in regular side
of the hammer.
Two, do a reversed grip upside down,
hit it with the back side of the hammer.
Okay, and then the last one,
you're going to do a regular grip
over the arm in.
And then you have to do
each one in order.
Split the wood.
[Music]
Okay.
So, first one is just regular?
Regular.
Then the next one is
upside down ball-peen.
[Music]
Oh boy.
You're not a kind man.
Oh, my arm is so tired.
[Music]
Ah!
Disaster strikes.
[Music]
So glad no one else
is home today.
Look how much better
than mine and is yours.
Yours is so crooked.
Yeah.
How did that happen?
Yours was really
a lot straighter than mine.
I'm going to say that was
pretty close to even.
Yeah, I think we both managed
to drive all three.
I did have more trouble
getting mine in.
You did, but you got it in.
I mean, [inaudible] at an angle I guess.
Wait. This is like those kids games,
you know the ones with all the pegs.
I saw a spark.
I saw a spark too.
I missed entirely.
So, what were your impressions
with hammer control?
I think that I need more of it.
So very much more of it.
But bending the nails
and all sorts of weird ways,
I think that is good training.
I think it would really help
me build up muscles,
and like, there's probably
a lot more muscles,
and variations of which muscles you're
using that people won't really think about.
So being able to turn it
at just the right angle
while still striking and stuff like that,
it's not just the same single muscle
as if you'd like pick up,
and strike your hammer over,
so you really need to have
experience twisting
and turning your hands.
So that when you want
the hammer to do something...
It does the thing that you want it to do.
It does the thing, instead
of some other thing,
which I had a lot of it
doing the other thing.
Guys, thanks for watching.
We hope you've learned
something good today.
But remember, there's
always more for you to see.
That box up at the top
will transport you
directly to our last video,
and you should check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you aren't a subscriber yet,
you should be.
Just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way, you will never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.